next question today hey David why is the
United States northeast and New England
so liberal if it started with
conservative pilgrims this is a great
question what you have to understand is
that today if we think back to the
pilgrims they are extremely conservative
by today's standards a Bernie Sanders
progressive from Boston today is way to
the left of a pilgrim that was in modern
day what is now Boston hundreds of years
ago okay but at the time they were
progressive given what they were doing
we talked about this in our video called
I think it's called the founding fathers
were progressive and you should be too
or something like that fighting the
powers of England to separate and become
independent with the idea of freedom of
and freedom from religion even though
they were religious at the time was a
radical progressive forward-thinking
idea at any particular point what you
have to understand is the people in the
northeast of the United States were the
progressives relative to whatever group
they were separating from or whatever
the alternative effectively was yes to
me today in 2019 as you know culturally
Jewish lefty millennial David Pakman
pilgrims seem outrageously conservative
to me but compared to the establishment
status quo people that they were
separating from at the time they were
progressive left wingers as you move
forward in time as evangelical
Christians started to spread to
different parts of the United States the
Northeast is almost not at all
evangelical evangelicals are one of the
most conservative branches of
Christianity instead in the Northeast
you've got Catholics and Quakers and
Unitarians and other sects and probably
I would argue although I haven't looked
at the numbers more Jews I mean
Massachusetts in New York I know have
more Jews than most of the US but maybe
some of these other northeast New
England states do as well --shoes one of
the most liberal voting group groups in
the country when you look at that you
realize oh yeah at any given time you
also had fewer of the most conservative
religious sects in
northeast relative to the Midwest and
the south with evangelicals and other
more conservative Christian groups but
there is even more than religion as well
because the history of education also
plays a big role in this if we zoom out
we know that when people are less
religious and more educated they tend to
be further progressive they tend to be
further to the left when you look at the
history of education and the
preponderance of great colleges in the
Northeast in Massachusetts in other
states in New England that tends to lead
to more democratic voting individuals
even though you have states like New
Hampshire and Vermont and Massachusetts
that have rural areas that you might
associate more with the Midwest and the
south and parts that tend to have more
conservatives overall you still have you
know even the rural areas in
Massachusetts are closer to urban areas
or semi urban areas they're closer to
other towns they are often college towns
which is a significant left leftward
pushing force and then the other thing
is also the distribution of the
Republicans in the Northeast you still
have plenty of Republicans in the
Northeast I mean I think even here in
Massachusetts Trump got close to 40% of
the vote which is I get it it's still it
ended up being more than a 20 point
margin for Hillary Clinton but almost
40% of one of the bluest states still
voted for Donald Trump the thing is they
are sort of sparsely distributed so that
they have a lesser electoral impact so
if I had to summarize it really
succinctly the reason why the Northeast
continues to be a very progressive part
of the country would be more education
less religion and some of the other kind
of geographical dynamics that tend to
appeal more to and be more common in
more progressive rather than
conservative areas